well let me uh ask about jacques
who is he
um you know him who's jacques valet
what have you learned from him
about life about about
about ufos about technology about our
role in the universe
well i met jacques actually soon after
the whole atacama thing happened
um
i was visited by those people associated
with the government and the whatever
around the
um
the havana what ended up mostly being
havana syndrome patients but also
jacques at the same time and they were
actually working behind the scenes with
each other that oh here's this stanford
professor
who is willing to talk about this stuff
and investigate things
um maybe we should go talk to him and he
he reached out through a colleague and
you know i had lunch actually um at the
rosewood inn
up on
near sandhill so jacques
is one of the first openly
active scientists
and he's really a scientist in this area
going back to the 1960s um
and uh
you know he's
put forward a number of ideas
speculations about what
it might be that people are interacting
with and he the first thing that i
learned from him is this notion of what
he called kabuki theater
that many of the things that people have
seen are i remember reading his books
and thinking he uses this word absurd a
lot
um he said the the things that people
claim they see are absurd
right
a a a ship doesn't land
in a farmer's field
and then come up and knock on the door
and say can i have a glass of water and
these are stories literally out of
newspapers from the 1930s
it's absurd
you know and the other thing that people
say ships don't crash if you're so
technologically advanced you don't crash
it's absurd
that they crash
so um
he says this is
put on as a show
it's meant to it's an influence
campaign
right it's it's not meant to influence
individuals it's meant to influence a
culture
as a whole maybe they don't look at us
as individuals maybe they look at us as
an organism
that lives on a planet
right and perhaps rightfully so
and so that's how you interact with them
that's how you influence them so that
was one of the first things that kind of
took me back and realized wow there's
actually a maybe there's a puppet
master behind the scenes
that's
you know doing this influencing that all
this stuff about aliens is just is not
true per se they're just a
representation of something
that is meant to influence so that was
probably the most interesting thing i
mean the man is brilliant
uh he's also it can be and i'm sorry
jacques he can also be incredibly
annoying
to have a conversation with
because he will pick apart your
arguments
or anything that you think you know and
show you why you don't know what you
think you know
and he uses the he used the example that
for me that is
is is all you need is one
counter example to any conclusion
and you're wrong
and so i learned from him i mean i'm
supposed to be a good scientist but i
learned from him
don't talk about conclusions just talk
about the data
because data's not wrong i mean convince
yourself that the data is not wrong or
not an artifact but be careful about
your conclusions because whatever is
going on it's it's much more complicated
than we than we imagine
wow that's powerful being able to always
step back because we get we humans get
excited yeah we start to jump to
conclusions from the data but always
step back powerful being able to always
step back because we get we humans get
excited yeah we start to jump to
conclusions from the data but always
step back well in some of my twitter
feeds when i dare to go on twitter
are full of well when are you going to
give us the answer
well you know science is not immediate
you're going to have to be patient and
even some of my science colleagues have
said well where's the data my answer to
them has been
where's been your work to try to produce
any
you know i'm not here to give you
everything on a silver platter
you